veamos si podemos resolver esta ecuación
cuadrática que tengo aquí x cuadrada
menos 2 x menos 8 igual a 0 pero esta
vez quiero resolverla de una manera
particular porque realmente varias
maneras en las que puedes atacar este
problema puedes intentar simplemente
factorizar el lado izquierdo y seguir
ese camino pero la manera en la que
nosotros vamos a resolverlo es
completando el cuadrado y eso qué
significa
bueno eso significa que vamos a escribir
este lado izquierdo que tenemos aquí lo
queremos escribir de la siguiente forma
como x + am esto elevado al cuadrado más
b y como veremos si podemos escribir el
lado izquierdo de esta ecuación de esta
forma ya va a ser muy sencillo que
resolvamos esta ecuación cuadrática
entonces veamos si podemos hacerlo pero
primero vamos a recordar cómo
necesitamos reacomodar el lado izquierdo
para llegar a esta forma que tengo aquí
si fueras expandir el
al cuadrado esta parte de aquí que me
quedaría si expandimos esto bueno pues
esto me quedaría el cuadrado el primero
x cuadrada más dos veces el primero por
el segundo 2
x más el cuadrado del segundo que es a
cuadrada y bueno claro no olvidemos esta
vez a esto le estamos sumando b entonces
veamos si podemos escribir esta parte de
aquí de esa forma y lo que vamos a hacer
es lo que se conoce típicamente como
completar el cuadrado entonces voy a
reescribir esta parte que tengo aquí
pero de una manera muy peculiar
voy a poner primero a x cuadrada después
a menos 2 x y después voy a dejar un
espacio por aquí un pequeño espacio para
después poner el menos 8 y después voy a
dejar otro pequeño espacio y después voy
a poner igual a cero
lo único que hice fue reescribir esta
ecuación que tengo aquí pero de una
manera muy peculiar porque esta manera
me va a servir para sumar y restar algo
que me va a ayudar a completar el
cuadrado perfecto entonces si
simplemente emparejamos primero tengo x
cuadrada y aquí también tengo x cuadrada
vamos bien después tengo aquí menos 2x y
aquí tengo más 2a x ok esto estaba muy
interesante
aquí tenemos 2x y aquí tengo menos 2x
eso quiere decir que entonces menos 2x
tendría que ser 2
x o dicho de otra manera 2 amp tendría
que ser menos 22 am tendría que ser lo
mismo que menos 2 o bueno si dividimos
todo a la mitad me quedaría que am tiene
que ser igual a menos uno observa lo que
estoy diciendo es que am será siempre la
mitad de tu coeficiente del
término de primer grado que tengas o lo
que es lo mismo también lo puedes ver
así la mitad del coeficiente x que
tengas en este caso el coeficiente con
el término x es menos 2 y entonces am
va a ser la mitad de eso la mitad de
menos 2 es menos 1 y luego queremos
tener a cuadrada y para tener a cuadrada
lo que necesitamos tener es aquí el
cuadrado de menos 1 y el cuadrado de
menos 1 es 1 entonces le voy a sumar 11
positivo lo voy a poner justo aquí pero
como hicimos y dijimos en los vídeos
pasados no podemos hacerlo así porque sí
porque sumar algo de un lado de la
ecuación sin sumarse lo al otro lado o
sin restarlo de nuevo al mismo lado es
fundamentalmente cambiar el valor de la
ecuación entonces y sume uno del lado
izquierdo tengo que sumar uno del lado
derecho para que esta ecuación se
mantenga o dicho de otra manera puedo
sumar 1 y restar 1 del mismo lado de la
ecuación
realmente no estoy cambiando el valor
del lado izquierdo de la ecuación se
mantiene porque lo único que estoy
haciendo es sumando 1 y restando 1 ahora
seguramente te estás preguntando por qué
hicimos esto y es que realmente no
cambie el valor de esta ecuación que
tengo aquí sume 1 y reste 1 pero lo hice
por una razón principal quiero que ahora
observes que esta parte que tengo aquí
es más déjenme ponerla con este color
esta parte del principio de nuestra
ecuación ahora concuerda con el patrón
que tengo aquí con x cuadrada + 2 x más
cuadrada ahora concuerda con esto que
tengo aquí aquí tengo a x cuadrada
después tengo a 2 a x y aquí tengo a
menos 2 en este caso a vale menos 1 y
después tengo a cuadrada que es menos 1
elevado al cuadrado y después tengo
menos 8 menos 1 lo cual va a equivaler a
la parte de ve esto que tengo aquí ahora
va a representar al menos 8 menos 1 es
menos 9 así que ya sabemos que b vale
menos 9 entonces todo esto lo podemos
reescribir de la siguiente manera esta
parte del principio me va a quedar como
x x y primero lo voy a poner así más o
menos 1 porque a vale menos 1 más menos
1 todo esto elevado al cuadrado observa
que tenemos el mismo patrón que tengo
aquí que lo podríamos factorizar como x
+ ha elevado al cuadrado o bien si
quieres para que no te confundas lo
puedo poner ya directo como x menos 1 -
1 esto elevado al cuadrado es
exactamente lo mismo que x cuadrado
menos 2 x 1 y luego tenemos este menos 9
déjame ponerlo así después tenemos este
menos 9 y después tenemos esta ecuación
igual a cero después tengo esto igualado
a cero y ahora si podemos sumar 9
a ambos lados de la ecuación voy a sumar
9 de lado izquierdo y 9 del lado derecho
de tal manera que déjame ponerlo así voy
a sumar estos 2 y estos 2 y estos dos se
van a cancelar y ya solamente me voy a
quedar con la expresión al cuadrado del
lado izquierdo de la ecuación me va a
quedar x menos 1 esto elevado al
cuadrado va a ser igual a hacer más 9 lo
cual es 9 y ahora si si tengo algo al
cuadrado que es igual a 9 eso significa
que ese algo debe de ser igual a la raíz
cuadrada positiva o negativa de 9
entonces x menos 1 va a ser igual a más
menos 3 a 3 positivo o 3 negativo
entonces déjame escribirlo aquí entonces
vamos a tener que
x menos 1 es igual a 3 positivo
x 1 x 1 es igual a menos 3 porque fíjate
si ponemos aquí 3 y lo elevamos al
cuadrado obtenemos 9 y si ponemos aquí
al menos 3 y lo elevamos al cuadrado
también obtenemos 9 así que para obtener
el valor de x que te parece si sumo uno
de ambos lados sumo uno de ambos lados
muy bien de este lado estos dos se van a
ir y voy a obtener que x es igual a tres
más uno lo cual es cuatro o en su dado
caso voy a sumar uno de ambos lados de
esta ecuación estos dos se van y me
queda que x es igual a menos tres más
uno lo cual es menos 2 entonces x igual
a 4 x igual a menos 2 son los valores de
x que satisfacen esta ecuación y ya
terminamos y bueno tal vez te estás
preguntando por qué nos tomamos la
molestia de completar al cuadrado ya que
pudimos ser capaces de factorizar esto
de una manera muy sencilla
este problema particular seguramente lo
pudimos haber hecho de una manera muy
sencilla pero completando el cuadrado es
un método muy poderoso ya que siempre lo
puedes aplicar y en un futuro aprenderás
la fórmula cuadrática y ésta viene
directamente de completar el cuadrado de
hecho cuando aplicas la formula
cuadrática esencialmente aplicas el
resultado de completando el cuadrado en
fin espero que hayas encontrado todo
esto muy divertido